Okay. So um the question we are looking
at today is how did English be how did
England become the greatest empire in
human history. This is about the 19th
century when the British Empire
um is at its peak. As you can see it
really controls most of the world. Um so
the question then is how did this
happen? Why is it that England was able
to surpass Spain, France, Germany, the
Holy Roman
Empire, Russia to become the dominant um
hegeimon in the world. So my argument to
you today is it has to do with the fact
that throughout its history, England was
forced to innovate in a more rigorous
and religious way than other nations and
a lot has to do with its
geography. Okay. So as you can see from
its geography
um Great Britain, this is Ireland, this
is England, Wales, Scotland, it is an
extremely mountainous
region and with very they have a lot of
rivers but there are no major rivers
which mean which meant that for most of
its history
uh Britain never had a major population
center that could grow and grow until it
overwhelmed the entire geographic um
area. This meant that for most of its
history, England um Britain was engaged
in a in a process what we call open
competitive cooperation.
Not only that, but because this area um
is very mountainous and because these
groups, these tribes are divided um
heavily amongst themselves. Throughout
most of its history, Britain is actually
pretty easy to invade. They have no
centralized authority. So it's possible
for um other groups of people to come
and create settlements in Britain which
is what the Vikings did which is also
what um the Romans the Annayiah uh so
throughout its
history Britain had undergo had
underwent a series of great destruction
where the elites were constantly
replaced by new elites. Okay. And
because Britain is poor, because there's
so much conflict uh within Britain,
eventually um the English people were
forced to migrate overseas to create new
opportunities. Um and this process of
colonial expansion led to the British
Empire. Okay, so there's a famous saying
that the British Empire was founded by
accident. Okay, there was no intention
to create this empire but because of
these historical geographic demographic
forces, Britain became the world's
largest empire. Um let's very quickly
look at Britain's demographic history.
So for most of it of its history because
of its geography, because of the fact
that it was poor and divided, the
population of Britain stayed very flat.
Okay, up until the year thousand. What
happened in the year thousand? Well,
Europe became wealthier and wealthier um
and engaged in a protoindustrial and
agricultural revolution which caused
demographic the the demographic to
increase. But
unfortunately, if your demographics
increase but you don't have improvements
in sanitation, in health, in nutrition,
well, what happens? You have something
called the black death, which causes the
entire population of Europe, including
Britain, to collapse. Okay. Um after the
black death um the uh Europeans start to
engage in the gunpowder revolution. Um
and with that you have
industrialization, urbanization and that
causes the population to increase. But
if you see about the middle of the 16th
cent 17th century up until about year up
until about 1800 the population is flat.
This is what we call the industrial
revolution in Britain. Britain is the
first European nation to undergo the
industrial revolution. What what that
meant is you have this massive migration
from the rural areas into the urban
areas especially London. Okay. So why
would this population or demographic
shift cause the population to stay flat?
Well, the first reason is it's really
really unsafe in the cities. diseases,
malnutrition, and lack of sanation cause
people to die really, really young. Also
during this time, because of the massive
inequality in Britain, people are forced
to migrate overseas in order to seek
better opportunities, mainly America,
but they will also go to Australia and
New Zealand. So even though the Dutch
were the first to discover and settle
Australia and New Zealand, it is really
the British who because of pressure back
home, they will settle in uh Australia
and New Zealand and and today Australia
and New Zealand of course uh British uh
they have a British culture instead of a
Dutch culture. Okay. Um starting in
about the year 1800 because of improve
improvements in nutrition, sanitation,
the population explodes. All right.
Okay. And this is true for throughout
Europe. And this is really why Europe
will eventually uh conquer the world.
All right. So let's go briefly into the
uh history of the British Isles. So at
first we believe that the British Isles
were settled by um an agricultural
people. Okay, these are the people who
built
Stonehenge. Now if you remember way back
to the beginning of this course um u
back in September I discussed Gobepe
righte is a temple um in Anatolia in
what is modern day Turkey that shows
that the desire for humans to settle
down and and found religious societies.
Well is very similar to Stonehenge.
There are both a astronom astronomical
calendars that measure um the stars
measure time and try to bring divine
energy onto
uh the earth in order in order to feed a
culture. Okay. So um you can argue that
what's happening is the goateeep culture
is spreading all throughout Europe and
it gets into the British Isles but
eventually these people are conquered by
the Yamna. Okay. And if you look at the
DNA evidence a lot of these people were
eventually wiped out by the Yamnia and
replaced. This is a process of great
destruction that will happen throughout
British
history. Um the next major development
is the Roman conquest of Britain. When
the Romans conquer Britain, they bring
Roman technology which is which is
acqued irrigation um uh
urbanization. They will also bring Roman
customs especially law. Okay. So now you
have a legal tradition in Britain that
continues on to
today. Um they will found a city called
Londinium which is now modern day London
on off the river themes. Okay. And this
city will eventually become uh the the
largest city in
Europe. After the Romans will come a new
group of people who are Germanic. Okay.
So these are people who used to live in
Denmark and northern Germany and because
of population pressure they are forced
to migrate overseas and they settle in
Britain. There are three different
tribes of people that settle in Britain.
They are the Angles, the Saxons, and the
Jukes. And together we will collectively
call them the
Anglo-Saxons. And at this point in
history, this culture, this language,
it's no different from that of Germany.
Okay? So, if you were to go to this
place in in about the year 800, they're
speaking the same language, which is
West Germanic, and today we call it old
English.
Um, again, what's really important to
remember is it's fairly easy to settle
down in Britain because there's no
centralized authority. So, after the
Anglo-Saxons comes the Vikings from
Denmark, okay? And um there even though
England has no major rivers, it has
still a lot of rivers. So, it's fairly
easy for the Vikings with their very
fast long ships to come and make
settlements. So as you can see the day
law are territory that is seated by the
Anglo-Saxons to the Vikings. Okay. And
now you have this merger of the Viking
culture with the Anglo-Saxon
culture. This process of great
destruction continues with a Norman
conquest of England. This is your year
1066. This battle is called the battle
of Hastings in which when the conqueror
of Normandy in France he comes and
conquers the um the the the British
Isles. Okay. Um Britain. Okay. This is
significant for two reasons. The first
reason is that the Normans are Vikings
who settled down in France in an area
called Normandy that's off the British
coast. And remember before the
Anglo-Saxons
uh were Germanic people so their focus
was on northern Europe because the
Normans conquer Britain. Britain now is
united with parts of France. Okay. So
Britain is drawn into the politics of
France which will lead to something
called the hundred years war it in which
um Britain the English are trying to
maintain their territory in France.
Okay. Okay, so that's the first major
geopolitical consequence of the Norman
conquest. The second consequence uh
which is also rather significant is a
radical change in the English language.
So before the Anglo-Saxon spoke a
Germanic language we call old English.
Now you have a merger of the Germanic
language with French and Latin. So
French is what the is the language that
the Norman spoke but Latin is the
official language of the educated elite
of Europe. Okay. So now you have Latin
and French elements blend into old
English and this creates a new language
we call middle English and in middle
English of course will give rise to
modern English. This is significant
because what makes middle English
different from um from old English is
middle English is a lot easier to learn
because remember now you have a very
cosmopolitan nature to Britain. You have
Vikings, you have Anglo-Saxons, you have
French, you have Normans. They all need
to speak one language. So the best
elements of these different languages
are blended into middle English. And
this tradition continues today because
if you think about it, English is the
most widely spoken language in the
world. Why? Because it's the easiest to
learn. All right? Now, you may argue
that, you know, it's because we live in
the Anglo-American Empire and therefore
people are incentivized to learn
English. But at the same time what I
will show you uh next class is um the
reason why they were able to establish
the Anglo-American Empire a lot has to
do with the fact that English is easy to
learn and therefore it's easier to
spread soft power right because when
when you learn a language you're not
just learning a language you're also
learning a culture you're learning a
history right and this what we call soft
power and the British did this better
than anyone else now the Americans do
this better better than anyone else
Okay. But it starts with the Norman
conquest in 1066. All
right. All right. Now, so as I
mentioned, what's really important um
about Britain is it really never had
centralized authority. Maybe now and
then you had a great king like Alfred
the Great, all right? But it was never
centralized because the king could never
assort assert authority over the
different thiefs. So whenever king does
that the nobles get together and they
rebel. So in 1215 king John tries to
impose taxes on the uh nobles in order
to finance wars in France right because
again uh the English are trying to
maintain their territory in France and
they come and that creates a lot of
conflict with the French themselves. So
they fight a lot of wars and you need
money to pay for these wars. So King
John was trying to make the nobles pay
taxes. So what the nobles do and this is
this is going to be consistent pattern
throughout British history is they rebel
and they force king John to sign a
document called the
manacarta. Okay the great charter and
the great charter is significant
because it severely limits the power of
the king. Now this has happened
throughout human history before where
the nobles uh rebel and they force a
compromise with the king. This has
happened throughout human history, but
this is actually the first time that
this is this has been written down and
become part of the British tradition.
Okay, this will become part of what we
call the British Constitution. What
makes the British Constitution unique is
it's not written down. It's not um a
document like the US Constitution is it
is a set of traditions and norms. Okay.
So this this begins the British
Constitution, the Magna Carta. Right.
What what I want to do now is look at
different um clauses in the manacard.
It's a very old document. So most of the
stipulation most of the clauses don't
really apply but there are three that do
apply. Okay. So I I want us to just look
at very closely at certain clauses
within the Magna Carta. All right.
Clause 10. If anyone who has borrowed a
sum of money from Jews dies before the
debt has been repaid, his here shall pay
no interest on the debt. Okay, this is
really interesting. This year 1215,
there are Jews in England. Okay, why are
there Jews in England? Okay, so let me
explain the history of
um Europe at this time. So Europe is
entirely Catholic. The Catholic religion
does not allow for something called
usery. And the the idea of usery is you
charge interest on
debt. Okay? because that goes against uh
the teachings of the Catholic Church
that goes against the teaching of God.
Also, it's socially destructive, right?
Because if you fall in a debt, you're
basically stuck there for all of
eternity. So, the Catholic Church for
explicitly forbids
uh charging interest on
debt. But this is really important, debt
is extremely profitable. So the way that
the king and the nobility get around
this taboo is they get
Jews, okay,
to lend out money and to charge debt and
then the king gets part of that, right?
Also because um Jews are heavily
disliked anyway because they engage in
money lending and usually the king also
gets them to go collect
taxes, right? So the Jews throughout
European history have been the
scapegoats for the elite. They're the
ones who charge usery. They're the ones
who collect taxes. They're also the ones
who will engage in uh businesses for the
nobles. Okay? So they basically
subcontract businesses from the nobles.
And they're very good at that. All
right? And why do Jews agree to do this?
because the king and nobles provide
protection to the Jews. Um so over time
you have this huge problem where even
nobles owe money to the Jews and the the
problem of debt creates a lot of social
tension within England. So in the Magna
card, it says very explicitly that yes,
you still owe money to Jews, but if you
die, your here does not have to pay
interest because the problem with debt
again is not the debt itself, the
principle, but the interest. Okay?
Right? So does that make sense to you
guys? Right? This is really important
because if you want to understand World
War II, if you want to understand the
Holocaust, it starts way back here.
Okay? All right. So the two most
important clauses in the magnolar that
still apply today is 39 and 40. All
right. So let's look at 39. No free man
shall be seized or
imprisoned except by the lawful judgment
of his equals or by the law of the land.
This creates a new principle in British
as we call due process. This means that
if you are if you commit a crime, you
are still
guaranteed a jury, a trial before you
are punished, right? There's a process
in which you are uh found guilty for
your crime. This is what we call due
process. Number 40, to no one will sell,
to no one, deny or delay, right or
justice. This
means that no one is above the law.
Okay. So, number 30 establishes the idea
of due process. Number 40 establishes
the idea of rule of law. Everyone is
guaranteed due process. Not even the
king has the power and authority to take
away due process from someone. All
right? And this establishes the British
common law tradition. And this becomes
the basis for the American constitution.
All
right? Okay. So as I mentioned because
of the Norman conquest Britain now is
forced to defend its territory in France
and this leads to a series of disastrous
wars um in France called the hundred
years war. I don't have time to go into
the history but obviously there are
certain very important figures that
emerge from 100 years war. The most
famous being Jon of Arc. Okay. Jon of
Arc who is this French mystic, a
teenager
uh girl who leads the French armies to
victory against the British and their
allies, right? Um during this time
there's also a civil war fought in
Britain called the War of the Roses
between the House of York and the House
of Lancaster. You may like the Game of
Thrones uh television series. I'm not
sure if you watched it, but that series
is actually based on the civil war
between the House of York and the House
of Lancaster. This goes on for a long
time. It's very very uh deadly. Um it
almost destroys Britain. But eventually
a man names Richard of York, Richard
III, he emerges victorious from this
civil war. Okay. But he has a problem.
His problem is his family, the house of
York, had to borrow a lot of money from
overseas, the Florentines, right? The
Meduchi, in order to finance the war.
Once he became king, he he thought,
well, I'm king and I don't have to pay
you back. Okay? So now the bankers are
angry at him. And if bankers are angry
at you, you have a problem because what
bankers will do in the circumstance is
finance an invasion of your country.
Okay? So the Medisi, the Florentine
bankers, they sponsored a man named
Henry Tudtor. Henry Tudtor who is of the
house of Lancaster. Okay. But he grew up
in f in France and they sponsor him to
invade England and defeat Richard III.
Okay. Okay. And this establishes the
house of tutor and the mo and so um the
um the Henry Tudtor becomes Henry VIIth
and his son becomes Henry VII with who
is most one of the most famous kings in
British history. He's famous
because he
decides to negate the authority of the
pope. He decides I'm the king. I don't
have to listen to anyone even the pope.
Okay. And this came to pass because
Henry VII was trying to divorce
Katherine of Aragon and the pope would
not agree. So the the Henry the e
decides to set up his own church called
the church of England and separate
himself from the Vatican. Now what's
really important to for us to remember
is there's only one difference only one
difference between the Church of England
and the Catholic Church. The Catholic
Church swears loyalty to the Pope. The
Church of England swears loyalty to the
King of England. That's it guys. There's
no other difference. The customs, the
doctrine, the rituals are all the same.
Okay? There's only one difference.
Um he will have a very famous daughter
called Queen Elizabeth. All right? So um
because of the
reformation, there's a huge religious
civil war going on between the Catholics
and the Protestants.
Okay. So, Elizabeth, why she is so
consequential is she's on a throne for
40 plus years. And what makes her
extremely significant is she brings
stability to England by sympathizing
with the Protestants, but but also by
working with the Catholics. Okay. So
even though there are all these Catholic
conspiracies against Elizabeth in order
to instill install a uh Catholic monarch
um she she's still able to resist these
conspiracies these rebellions and
establish a pretty stable nation at the
same time dur during her reign uh
Shakespeare will write his place. Next
class we are doing Shakespeare okay
because Shakespeare there would be no
English language. If there's no English
language, you can also argue there'd be
no British Empire. So next class, we'll
spend an entire class on analyzing how
Shakespeare created the English language
and created the possibility of the
British Empire. Okay, that's next class.
Um, Francis Drake is the most famous
pirate at this time
and he is a trusted deputy of Elizabeth.
Elizabeth has a policy of piracy, right?
England is poor, Spain is rich. So what
do you do? You steal from the rich and
you give to the poor, right? And that's
what surf Drake did. Um, so at this
time, England is emerging as a naval
power and it's it's going to surpass
both Spain and France, become the
dominant navy in the world. And as you
know, it's really the navy that allows
the British Empire to control the world.
Um the major innovation of the British
of the English is how they fight at sea.
Traditionally the way you fight naval
battles is by ramming the enemy and then
boarding the ship and then call killing
everyone. Okay, that's what the Romans
did. That's what everyone did. The
English decided that's silly because
we're always outnumbered. We're always
outmen. Okay, so they pioneered long
range cannon warfare where from a
distance maybe a few hundred meters you
will blast your enemy with cannons.
There are lots and lots of problems with
this. Okay, the first problem is um you
could possibly sink your ship because
the cannons are very heavy. Also, you
could blow up your own ship because the
cannons are very explosive. Also, the
cannons aren't very accurate. Okay. So,
but the English persisted even though
you can make the argument that this um
type of warfare it's unsustainable.
Okay. And in the beginning for the first
few decades the way they fought was
terrible. But the thing about the
British that made them very similar to
the Romans is they were relentless. They
were willing to suffer heavy casualties,
major setbacks, major fail failures and
still persist until they eventually won.
Okay, that's the mentality of the
British. That's very Roman. All right,
so um this is 1588, the battle of the
Spanish Amarda. Okay, and this is
something that's heavily c celebrated in
England because for the English, it
marks the day when the British Navy
reigned supreme over the seas. Okay,
this is a day that the Spanish marta was
conquered and destroyed by the English.
Um something that's really important for
us to remember is that
um in a year later in 1589 the Spanish
will defeat the English and the English
will suffer tens of thousands of
casualties. Okay. So what's important
for us to remember is that these wars go
back and forth. There's no one time when
okay now the British are dominant. Okay.
What matters is persistence. What
matters is resilience. And in this in in
that respect the English are far
superior to the European um
adversaries. Okay. Um so Queen Elizabeth
dies and King James of Scotland inherits
the English throne. Okay. So now
Scotland and England are united. What's
significant about King James is he
produces something called the King James
Holy Bible. This is something that the
Protestants have been um demanding for a
long long time. Remember the difference
between the protest and the Catholics is
the Catholics are not allowed to read
the Bible. The priests tell the uh
parishioners what to believe. What the
orthodoxy is the Protestant believe that
everyone must read the Bible. So the
King James Bible is the first time that
the Bible has been mass-produced for
everyone. Okay. So this spreads protest
very quickly throughout the um uh uh
British Isles. Also what's really
significant is with the Bible now you've
standardized the language. Okay, now you
can make a transition from middle
English to modern English language we
speak today.
Um 1620 is significant because it's the
year when the pilgrims on the Mayflower
they move to America to found a new
colony, a new civilization, a new empire
uh that will take over the world. Okay.
Why are the pilgrims moving to America?
Well, the protests are divided into two
major factions at this time. You have
the Puritans. Who are the Puritans? The
Puritans believe that the Church of
England it's too Catholic and therefore
we must purge the Church of England of
Catholic tendencies like rituals like uh
priests.
Okay. The pilgrims are what call
separatists. Okay. So there's another
group called the pilgrims the
separatists who believe the church of
England it's too corrupt, it's too evil,
it's too much like the Vatican.
Therefore, we should abolish it or we
should just separate uh from it. And so,
of course, they were persecuted by the
king. And as a compromise, the programs
were allowed to go to America to build a
new civilization based on their beliefs.
And the civilization, of course, what we
call America, right? So, that's
something that you must remember that
America was founded by programs who want
to build a kingdom uh of heaven on
earth. And we'll discuss this next week
when we discuss the American Revolution
back in uh
England. There is a civil war now
raging. Okay. And it starts again when
the king tries to impose too much
authority over the nobles. But there are
there's also a religious dimension to
it. Uh because the Puritans want to
impose a religious state on everyone.
Okay. So the fanatics at at the stage
are the Puritans. And what will happen
is the Puritans will emerge triumphant
under the leadership of Oliver Cromwell
and he will establish something called
the Commonwealth of England. And this is
a disaster. It doesn't really work out
well because it goes against British
tradition. Remember the idea of the
Puritans is they want to establish a
religious centralized theocracy on
England. But England has always been uh
pretty independent and autonomous.
So what will happen is after Cromwell
dies, the Cromwell goes away and the
nobles reinstate a new king. Okay? Uh
who is Charles II. After he dies, James
the second will take the throne. The
problem with James II is he's a
Catholic. Okay? He's a Catholic. And so
there are a lot of English who are who
are afraid that he will that he will
move too close to France, Spain, and the
Vatican. And these are um British
enemies. Okay. So what will happen is
this. The nobles will invite a Dutch
king Wilm of Orange who who is of
British um blood to come to England in
the year 1688. And the Wilm of Orange
will bring about 10,000 soldiers to
Britain. This is an invasion. This is
the very last invasion that succeeds in
Britain. King James has a larger army.
But what will happen is King James is
not very decisive. He's not very
effective. So a lot of his army will
desert him. So basically his army sort
of dis dissipates and he's allowed to go
to France. And one of Orange bloodless
not not bloodlessly but he's but he's
very quickly able to assume the throne.
And this is significant because and this
is called the glorious revolution. This
is significant
because it establishes for the first
time officially the sovereignty of
parliament over the king. Okay, does
that okay? This is really important.
Okay, now it's official. Parliament is
the ultimate authority, ultimate
sovereignty in Britain and the king is a
figurehead, right? All right. And this
is significant um because it will now
allow Britain to energize the middle
class. If you're middle class, you now
have an incentive to work hard because
now there's patents, there's trademarks.
There's incentive for you to get rich.
And this will lead to of course the
industrial revolution. All right? So the
glorious revolution is one of the main
contributing factors to uh the
industrial revolution in Britain.
This is also significant because in
1694, the Bank of England is
established. All right. Now, I I can't
emphasize
enough what a huge deal this is. All
right. So, let me slowly explain why
this is a big deal. And I want I want to
make sure you understand because now we
go into into into finance and economics.
And I really haven't taught finance
economics before. I I want to make sure
that you understand the idea here. Okay.
So before if you're a king and you want
to fight a war, what you do is you
borrow money from the rich and these are
usually cortels. All right. So um
Charles the second borrowed a lot of
money to fight wars from the goldsmiths
of um London including a group of Jews.
Okay. And then he refused to pay it
back. Now you have a problem because now
you have um a credit crisis. You have a
trust crisis, right? If the king refuses
to pay back the rich for their uh loan,
why would the king ever be able to raise
funds ever again? Okay, so Parliament
solves this problem because now because
now if Parliament is the central
authority, the central sovereignty in
the land, then you are not lending money
to the king. you are lending money to
the
nation, right? If a king dies or a king
is deposed, you're screwed. You're not
getting your money back. But if you lend
money to the nation, the people through
the parliament, then you are always
guaranteed to get your money
back unless England gets conquered.
Okay? But we know because of the navy,
England cannot be conquered. And so not
only are the rich willing to lend money
to the nation now to finance wars, but
also foreigners, especially the Dutch,
right? Because the Dutch were were very
wealthy and they need a safe place to
put their money. So where what's where's
the safest place in the world to put
your money now? England, right? Because
if you are in the Netherlands, you can
be conquered by the French or the
Germans, which happen which happens a
lot. But if your money, if your gold,
and this is gold, right, goes to London,
no one's going to touch that, be able to
touch that. Okay? So now the Bank of
England
allows Britain to borrow money from its
people, from foreigners, and from the
future by printing money, right? By
issuing war bonds. And therefore,
Britain has infinite financing. And this
is a major reason. This is the main
reason why Britain was able to defeat
Napoleon, right? It took seven wars,
seven coalitions to defeat Napoleon.
Each of these coalitions was financed by
Britain. Okay? And once Napoleon was
defeated, Britain became the hedgeimon
of the world. It became the British
Empire. No one could now challenge the
might of Britain. Okay? So you
understand the impact of central
banking. Okay, central banking allows
you to mortgage your nation's future in
the pursuit of total war. It allows you
to weaponize the trust and confidence of
your people. Okay, does that make sense?
But there's a problem. Okay, this is
really important. There's a problem with
this innovation. The problem is this.
Once you commit to a war, once you raise
debt and commit to war, you're forced to
fight the war until the very bitter end.
Right? Because if you lose the war, your
nation goes bankrupt. Does that make
sense, guys? Okay? That's why Britain
refused to ever compromise with
Napoleon, right? Napoleon said to
Britain, "Hey guys, I control um all of
Europe. Let's talk peace. let's just
trade peacefully. And Britain says, "No,
we can't do that because we lent a lot
of money to the Austrians, the
Prussians, and the Germans, and the
Russians in order to defeat you. If we
sign a deal of peace, all money is now
gone. And we, the Bank of England, we
the British nation is completely wiped
out. We are completely wiped out." Okay?
Do you understand? This is really
important for the future history of
Europe. If Britain fights a war, it does
so through financing. It does so through
debt. But because it does so through
debt, it has to fight the war until it
wins. It can never ever compromise. It
can never ever
surrender. All
right? And this is important because
this explains what happened in World War
I, World War II, and this also explains
um and I I'll I'll discuss this towards
the end of the semester. It also
explains American foreign policy.
Okay. Okay. Was that clear to you guys?
Any questions about what we've learned
so
far? Okay. Now, I want to talk about
political
philosophy of the British. Okay. Because
again, we discussed this throughout um
this course. You can have new ideas, but
now you have to justify these new ideas.
You have to explain uh the innovation
through philosophy to the people. Okay.
So um Britain at this time is is really
famous for its political philosophers at
this time. Thomas Hobbes um is one of
the most dominant political
philosophers. He lived through the
English civil war. He saw all the chaos,
all the destruction and he wrote a book
called Leviathon. Leviathon is to
justify why Britain returned to a
monarchy instead of maintaining a
commonwealth. Okay. And this is the most
famous passage from his book Leviathon
which you'll probably read in
university. Okay. There is no place for
industry because the fruit thereof is
uncertain and consequently no culture of
the earth. No navigation nor use of
commodities that may be imported by sea,
no commodious building, no arts, no
letters, no society and which is worse
of all continual fear and danger of
violent death. The life of man,
solitary, poor, nasty, Buddhist and
short. Okay. So, um he's trying to
explain why there's government and so he
gives the idea like we were born in a
state of nature and we're free to do
whatever we want. We can kill, we can
love, we can steal, we can do what
whatever we want. So why would we give
up this freedom in order to enter a
state of nature? So in order to have
government the answer is because state
of nature sucks. Okay? Because you can
be killed because because things will be
stolen from you because there'll be no
innovation. So no matter how bad
government is, it's absolutely
necessary.
Okay. Now this is John Lock. Okay. And
John Lock is writing during the time of
the glorious revolution. He is a
supporter of parliament. He's a
supporter of the glorious revolution.
Okay. And he and he writes something
called uh so 1688 is glorious
revolution. In 1689 he will publish um
the second treaties on government. And
this is his most famous work. Okay.
Again, when you go to university, you
will have to study the second treatise.
But in it, he basically explains that,
okay, Hobbes is right. We are born in a
state of nature and we do need
government. But let's remember this.
When we're born in a state of nature, we
are born with certain inalienable
rights. And these three rights are the
right to life, liberty, and the pursuit
of property. The proper function of
government is to maintain our rights.
The government does not do that. Then we
have the flexibility. We have the
freedom to rebel against the government.
Okay. So Hobbes is saying government is
necessary. You can never ever challenge
it because if you do things will get
much worse. Lo is saying government is
only legitimate if it guarantees us our
inelible rights. Right? So lo is
considered the founder of liberalism and
his ideas will become the basis for the
US constitution which will which we will
study next Thursday. Okay. So I I want
you to remember this. All right. Now
what I'm doing now and this is really
important okay is compare and contrast
the British enlightenment with the
European enlightenment. Remember before
we did the European enlightenment we
studied Rouso. We studied Kant uh
Voltier. Okay. And I told you the
British enlightenment is very different
from the European Enlightenment in three
major ways. Okay. So now what I will do
is explain what the differences are.
Okay. All right. So let's compare Rouso
and Loach. Loach um uh published his
theories um at the end of the 17th
century. Rouso comes about 50 years
later. Okay. And Rouso will give us a
French revolution. So there are three
major differences I want you to remember
between British uh political philosophy
and European political philosophy. Okay.
The first is this. Loach believes that
we are born tabula rasa the blank slate.
Okay. Which means that we are influenced
by the environment. If our parents are
nice to us we'll be good people. Our
parents are mean to us we'll become bad
people. Tabua rasa. Okay. We are
controlled, nurtured by the environment.
We're so the Europeans believe no we are
born inherently good. Not only that, we
were born with the capacity to reason if
we are given the freedom to reason.
Remember when we discussed Rouso, he
said do not educate your child before
the age of 12 because if you do, you'll
just screw up the child. Okay? And the
idea is there's a natural capacity in us
that will grow over time that allows us
to reason naturally. So Russo believed
this but also Kant believe this as well.
Okay. So that's a huge difference,
right? Second major difference is this.
Lo believes the purpose of society is
liberty. Liberty just means you are free
to do whatever you want. If you want to
eat ice cream, go ahead and do it. Yes,
ice cream will make you fat. Ice cream
will um uh maybe increase your chole
cholesterol, but you should have the
freedom, the liberty to to make that
choice. Okay, that's the purpose of
society to give you the liberty to make
bad
choices. For Rouso, the purpose of
society is reason. Society, if it's
good, should enable you to reason
properly. Okay. So uh the Europeans
believe that society should be much more
interventionist. It should help you
become more reasonable because reason is
what allows for freedom. Okay. And the
last major difference and this is key.
Okay guys, I I need you guys to remember
these three differences. The last major
difference is
this. How do you base laws? On what
basis do you have laws? Okay. And so for
luck, the answer is very simple.
Tradition, guys. It's just what we've
been doing all this time, right? British
common law. If the Romans did it and
we're still doing it, it's probably for
a reason. It's probably because it
works. But for Rouso and the Europeans,
it's general will. Remember, okay, so
just remind you, general will is what is
in the best interest of people. Okay,
this is really important. It's not what
people want. It's what the majority
says. It's what is in the best interest
of people. So Rouso talks about this a
lot where okay if you let people if you
let people vote there's a danger that
they'll be influenced by a minority who
manipulates them. Okay the idea of the
general will is think about this using a
reason. Think about what is in the best
interest of everyone. All right so if
everyone's like you know I want free ice
cream. Okay this entire school says I
want free ice cream then we should give
you free ice cream according to law.
Right. But according to Rouso, no, we
cannot give you ice cream because if you
sit down independently and think about
what is your in your best interest, you
would know that ice cream is bad for
you. Therefore, we should not give you
ice cream. Okay? The general wheel is
what is in the best interest of everyone
involved. Not necessarily what you vote
for, not necessarily what you believe,
but what is in your best interest. Okay?
If you have reason, if you have the
capacity to reason. All right?
Now let's just summarize what the
difference is. The Europeans always
asking what is good, what is right. The
British and then later on the Americans
only ask what works. Okay, what
works? What is the least worst world we
can live in? Okay, so the British are
practical. You you can also say the
British are utitarian where the
Europeans are romantic and they are
idealistic. All
right. Also, and this is really
important because Rouso's on our
thinking will give us the philosophies
of communism and
Nazism. Okay. Does that make sense? And
of course, Lock's ideas will give us the
US Constitution. Right? So, this is part
of the
Anglo-American political tradition. This
will now become the European tradition,
which will give us Marxism and
communism.
All right. All right. Let's continue.
So, one one of the most important
political philosophers in Britain is
Jeremy Bentham. And he's the founder of
something called
utilitarianism. Okay. So,
um Bentham agrees with Loach and that we
need a more liberal society. We need a
more progressive society. But for him
it's really a question of like how do
you mathematically and logically come to
the point where you have a tolerant
liberal progressive society and so he
develops the idea of utitarianism okay
the idea of utterism is there are two
principles that govern the universe okay
that motivate us there's the pleasure
principle and there's a pain principle
okay and so what he says is if if
something makes us happy it's inherently
good. If something is makes us feel
pain, it's inherently bad. Okay. So, we
should we should structure a society
that mathematically calculates
um the amount of pain and pleasure we
produce and then we should
maximize the pleasure and reduce the
pain. Okay? And if you if you do that,
then you get to the same point of lock
where people should be guaranteed
liberty. People should be allowed to do
whatever they want as long as it doesn't
really harm other people. Okay? If you
want to eat ice cream, go eat ice cream.
You're not harming
anyone. All right?
Um obviously there are lots of issues
with this theory of utenism. So along
comes his disciple John Stewart Mill.
And John Stewart Mill is considered uh
the most significant political
philosopher of the past 200 years. Okay?
He is the founder of what we call
classical liberalism. The very basis of
classical liberalism is people should be
free to do whatever they want as long as
it doesn't hurt anyone. Also, people
should be allowed to say whatever they
want because free debate, free open
debate is what allows for society to
progress. Okay. So, what John Mill does
is he takes the principles of utenism
and refineses it
um in order to explain
why classical liberalism is the best
philosophy out there. Okay. And
classical liberalism will include uh
women's rights. Okay. It will include
prison reform. It will include u a more
egalitarian society.
Okay. All right. So
um another thing that lock sorry John
Mill that does that's very important is
he explains pleasure is not what you
think it is. Okay. Pleasure isn't like,
okay, whatever makes me happy. Because
there are different types of pleasure.
There's short-term pleasure and there's
long-term pleasure, right? Short-term
pleasure is eating ice cream every day.
Long-term pleasure is having a healthy
body and you can which which allows you
to climb mountains, which allows you to
uh enjoy life more. Okay. Short-term
pleasure is just watching Tik Tok
videos. long-term pleasure is being able
to read Shakespeare, being able to read
Dante, and being able to enjoy life
more. Okay? So that is this major
refinement of banam. Just because you
enjoy something today doesn't mean it's
good for you. So, so we have the
capacity to understand there's
short-term pleasure and there's
long-term pleasure. Okay? Long-term
pleasure is what he refers to as
happiness. The purpose of life is to be
happy. It's not necessarily to seek
pleasure. It's it's but it's the the
purpose is to
um to seek happiness. Okay. All right.
So this is a very rough in introduction.
Um you will learn all this stuff when
you get to university. Okay. All right.
So the these are the reasons why the
British Empire came to conquer the
world. Okay. All right. its history, its
geography, its demographics forces it to
engage in a continuous series of
innovation. This innovation will allow
it to eventually dominate the entire
world. And even though the British
Empire is gone, we still have the common
the British Commonwealth. Okay. So,
these are nations that speak English
that um believe British culture it's the
best in the world and who believe that
um working together in a community will
be beneficial for all. Okay. The British
Commonwealth. Okay. And that's a legacy
we still have of the British
Empire. Okay. So, now that I've done a
brief introduction, what I want to do
now is summarize the main points so that
you uh so that you have a pretty clear
framework to work with as we progress
into the American Empire.
Okay. All right. So, what I'm going to
do now is just summarize what we've
learned into a story of the British
Empire. Right. So, what was this clear
to you guys?
All right. So, let's now just summarize
what we've
learned.
Sorry. All right. So, there are many
many reasons why the British Empire came
to dominate the world. Okay. But the
three things I want to highlight today
is the Royal
Navy. Okay. So, the thing to remember
about the Royal Navy is its main purpose
is actually not to engage in war and
conquest. Its main purpose is actually
to to maintain global
trade. Why? Because remember Britain is
the first nation to industrialize.
Therefore, it's producing a lot of
finished goods. If you have finished
goods, you need markets. So the Brit the
British Navy, its main purpose is to
open up new markets and then to maintain
safe trade routes
uh against pirates. Okay. To facilitate
global trade. So, and this of course
made Britain extremely wealthy. Second
major reason is the Bank of
England, right? I cannot stress enough
how important this innovation was. Also,
what's really important first remember
is the Bank of England was
private. Okay, private. So they have the
powers of a central bank, the power
to print money, issue currency, the
power to issue debt, sell bonds, but it
was private, meaning it was controlled
by rich
stockholders. Okay? And the reason why
they did this is
um it was just the easiest way in order
to raise money quickly. Okay, if that
makes sense, right? Right? Because if
you're if you are a public person, you
may not want to give your money to to
the government. But you're a rich
person, where are you going to put your
money? You're going to put your money uh
into a a central bank that's that's
supported by the government. Okay. All
right. Uh and the third major reason
is English. All right. So the
development of English, which is again
the e the world's easiest language to
learn. So most languages in order to
speak it well you have you have you
actually have to grow up in a place
right? So if you want you want to speak
Chinese very well then the best solution
is to be born in
China but English is different. English
is you can learn at any age and still
have a pretty good command of the
language. Okay that's a huge innovation
uh in human history. All right. So now
let's let's try to figure out why was
England able to achieve these three
major innovations okay and not other
places okay the first principle is the
idea of
open
cooperative
competition which I will explain. Okay.
Second is this idea of creative
destruction meaning the elite is being
constantly replaced by a new elite that
brings in new ideas. The
third is
expansion. Okay. So colonial expansion
where the British are the English are
forced to migrate overseas instead of
Canada, the United States, uh Australia,
New Zealand um and other places as well.
Okay. but per p per p per p per p per p
per p per p per p per p per p
permanently these places. So these are
the three major factors that drive uh
innovation and because of all this
constant process of of innovation you
have Britain develop a navy a bank and a
new language that is fairly easy to
learn. All right, really quickly I'm
going to discuss the idea of open
cooperative competition. All right. So
historically civilizations develop like
on a major
river. So if you look at China, China
developed on the Yangze. Egypt developed
on the Nile. Mesop Mesopania developed
on the Tigress and Euphrates. India
developed on the Indis Valley. Okay? And
the Ganges. Why? Because if you have a
major river, you can build a settlement
and then for
irrigation you can expand your
population. Okay? And once your
population expands, it will allow you to
colonize other areas and then your
population keeps on growing before it
becomes a dominant civilization in an
era in in in an area. Okay, does that
make sense? Britain is different and
Europe is different. Why?
Because there are no major rivers and
therefore the
population is constant. You never have a
need to go conquer new territory. You
just want to protect your your own
territory. Okay? But because the
population is so so uh diffused and
limited, it allows for foreign
conquest. Okay, which allows for credit
destruction and that's the main factor
driving innovation in
Britain. Right? So that's the history of
the British Empire. Any questions?
Anything you guys are not clear
about? Feel free to ask any questions,
okay? But like please make sure you guys
understand the logic of this because
we're going to build on this as we go
further and further. uh in into the
present. Okay. And remember this is
being influenced by the Dutch who will
now and then this these ideas will then
go go on to influence America. Okay. So
America basically just takes all the
ideas of the British Empire for
itself. All right. So it's really
important you understand what's driving
the British Empire.
Just a small question. Sure.
the the Puritans.
Okay. Um All right, guys. All right. So,
let's go into So, so question is, what's
the difference between the Puritans and
the pilgrims? Okay. Um let's go
into the problem of
religion in England at this time. Okay.
So when you have a
diversity, okay, when you have diversity
in England and so even though England is
a small place as I keep on saying a lot
of control is localized, okay, so if you
cross from one village to the next, the
culture can be very different, right? So
this is a feudal system. So you have a
lot of diversity. So this diversity is
going to impact your religious
outlook. Okay? So um what's going to
happen is
this.
So England is
Catholic and then the Henry VI is going
to turn this into the church of England.
But then what's going to happen is you
will have new ideas basically Calvinism
come in from Europe. Okay. Why is
communism important? It's
because England is the first to
industrialize. It's the first to have a
middle class. It's the first to have
merchants. Merchants prefer
Calvinism to Catholism. Right? In
Catholic in the Catholic religion, you
have to give all your money to the
church.
But in a communist religion, you have to
keep your money for yourself, right? So
communism is a much more popular
religion in Britain than the Catholic
religion in England as England begins to
industrialize. And so the middle class
is rising in
power.
Okay? And the problem is the response
the Church of England. Okay? Okay, the
Church of England, it's not Catholic,
but it's it's using a lot of Catholic
principles. And the Calvinist, the thing
about the Calvinist is they're fanatics,
okay? They they believe everyone should
be a Calvinist. Everyone should believe
in hard work. Everyone should be like
us, okay? And the Pope is evil. So the
Calvinists are not very tolerant. So
there are two major responses to the
Church of England. Okay? There's the
idea of
reform and then it's the idea of
dissolution. All right. So the idea of
reform is look the church of England
it's fine but there are certain things
within the church of England which is
too much like the Catholic Church. So we
get if we get rid of these things we'll
be good.
Okay. So but within the reform movement
you have different factions as as well.
Okay. So there are some who want to
replace the governance structure of the
church of England because the church of
England is controlled by the king and
they believe no we should all be
obedient to God not the king. So they
they want to destroy the hierarchy the
governance. There are some who want
everyone to read the Bible. There are
some who want to change the nature of
the priesthood. Okay. So there different
theories of change. Okay. And these
group of people we call the
Puritans. Okay. the Puritans. But then
you have a minority who are extremely
violent and fanatical and they believe
no let's just get rid of the Church of
England period because there should be
no earthly authority before God. Okay?
These people we call
separatists. Okay? And they will become
the pilgrims because obviously the king
pers will persecute these people. They
will feel the king sees them as a threat
and they will be persecuted. They'll be
outlawed. A lot of them will be
executed. So a lot of them will flee to
America in order to practice their
religion. Okay? In order to found a a
new
religion. All right? So the pilgrims are
the ones who flee. The Puritans are the
ones who will stay and eventually engage
in the civil war and overall the king.
But remember this, okay? While this is
happening, while this is happening, and
this is really important, there's also a
counterreaction. Okay? So there are
these
Catholics who want to
return England into the Catholic fold
and there um so Scotland is is very
Catholic. Okay. Um you also have um
other people called the
Armenians
who want to maintain the Church of
England as it is. Okay. So you have all
these massive factions emerging and
they're all in conflict over religion
and religion is a proxy for um economic
class as well. Okay. So it's obviously
the middle class who support reform and
there are a lot of nobles who um support
the Catholic religion and the king is
primarily um a sympathizer of the
Catholic religion. All right. So during
the glorious revolution they will make a
stipulation that no king can ever be a
Catholic. Okay? And that's a way to
limit the power of the king because if
you're a Catholic king you can draw on
the French, the Vatican, the Spanish as
allies in your suppression of the nobles
and of the middle class of parliament.
Okay. So there's there's a fear that the
king will ally with um the Catholic in
order in order to destroy the authority
of parliament and so after glorious
revolution a major reform is the king
cannot be Catholic and in fact if you're
here to the throne but if the parliament
suspects you have Catholic sympathies
they will replace you with someone else.
Parliament has that power and and they
did that actually um um dur during its
history. Okay. So there's a deep fear of
the Catholic religion within the um
within um the among English people.
Okay. But as you can see this is a very
complicated process that will take about
200 years to fully play out. Okay. Does
does that make sense? What's really
important for us to remember is this
conflict is being for the pilgrims is is
now migrating to America and these
people will make America into the most
religious fanatical intolerant place on
earth in certain places in America.
Okay? And it's a tradition that still
continues today. There are some certain
parts of America that are extremely
tolerant like New York City and Los
Angeles. But hey, go to, I don't know,
Alabama, Mississippi, Arkansas. They're
not very tolerant people. Okay? And you
you can make the argument that they are
the most fanatical people in the whole
world. Much more so than the Jews, much
more so than
uh the
Muslims.
Okay. So, does that answer your
question? Great. Any more questions?
You know, that's a great question. Okay.
So, how much power does a king have?
Okay. So, um the thing about the British
is because it's a system based on
tradition, there's a lot of flexibility
built into the system. So, depending on
the personality of the
king, the king can have a lot of power.
Okay? So for example, Henry VII was a
very powerful king and considered one of
the most powerful kings in the world.
Why? First of all, because he was a huge
guy. He was extremely charismatic. He
was a huge guy that was very good at
winning friends with the nobles. Okay?
So he's very good at building
alliances. Also he was in power for a
long long time over 50 years. Okay?
Okay. So he's able to slowly insert his
um prodigies, his minions into positions
of authority. Okay. And also uh he was
also very popular because he took
England away from the Catholic Church.
Okay. So the power of the king it's not
written down. It has to do and a lot of
his power has to do with his
personality,
um his longevity, his alliances, his
charisma. Okay? So there are a lot of
different factors in place. And that's
why the British think their constitution
it's the most perfect in the world
because it's not written down. So
they're not actually constrained by
words. It's but there's traditions that
allow the constitution to be living.
Okay? to be flexible and to be pertinent
to the present. Okay. And and and and so
the English are extremely proud of their
constitution. Does that make sense?
Okay. America learns from
Okay. So um that's a great question. So
if these pilgrims went over to
America, how was America able to become
this multicultural empire? Right?
because that goes against a lot of
paratonical teachings and the answer
which we'll discuss next week is
America is a
coalition of conflicts. Okay, it is it
is a melting pot of
differences. Okay, so what what I will
teach you next Thursday when we do the
American Revolution is there are two
dominant strands in the founding of
America. There's the pilgrim strand
which is puritanical which is like let's
create a theocracy but there's also a
enlightenment
strand where they believe that they're
founding a new empire based on reason
and so the religion we use for them is
uh theism okay these are das and most of
the founding fathers Thomas Jefferson
Alexander Hamilton George Washington
were theists they wanted to found a
tolerant multicultural
empire. Okay, so these are two dominant
strands in America. And quite honestly,
what's really important is if you want
to understand what's happening in
America today, Donald Trump, right? You
need to understand that it's these two
strands that have always been present in
America that now come into conflict with
each other. Okay? because you have on
the left these multiculturists
um like Barack Obama who believe that
America is great because America
welcomes immigrants and you have people
like JD Vance and and there are lots of
others as well who on on the
conservative side who say no America is
great because we are Christian okay
because we have this tradition of
Christianity that's what makes us great
and right now we're losing our
Christianity due to multiculturalism and
therefore we must close our borders
therefore or we we must reassert the
Christian faith in our nation. Okay. So,
so we will discuss this next Thursday
when when we do America, but this will
but but but as as this course
progresses, I will show you how
complicated America is and show you um
that because of this conflict, America
is probably is probably headed towards a
civil war. Okay, if that makes sense to
you. All right, great. Any more
questions,
guys? Okay, so um next class we'll do
William Shakespeare and then after
William Shakespeare we'll do the
American Revolution. Okay.